vamos a hablar ahora de china y eeuu
porque aumentan las tensiones entre esos
países tras la amenaza de un boicot
diplomático en los juegos olímpicos de
beijing esta atención diplomática que se
está llevando ahora el plano deportivo
porque este jueves el presidente jobvite
confirmó lo que había adelantado en
washington post y que repasamos aquí con
nuestra compañera rosa pérez en la
revista de prensa el mandatario afirmó
que estaban considerando un boicot
diplomático para estos juegos de beijing
las justas se inauguran el próximo 4 de
febrero y varias organizaciones en
defensa de los derechos humanos han
expresado su rechazo hacia este evento
sobre todo por los abusos en la región
de sangin y las violaciones contra la
minoría minoría uigur las palabras de
bailén tuvieron lugar tres días después
de esa esperada reunión virtual con su
homólogo chino en la que dijeron
comprometerse por una mayor estabilidad
la respuesta del gigante asiático llegó
este viernes
politizar el deporte va en contra del
espíritu olímpico y lastima los
intereses de los atletas de todos los
países sean dalí y me fan eeuu ha hecho
acusaciones contra china por temas de
derechos humanos y esto es inconsistente
con la verdad y no tiene fundamentos